let's stick with the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's try our caller from the 3
0 2 area code 3 0 2 go ahead hello David
I just came to call in regards to like
their revelation of the identity of
Austin serial killer bomber okay and it
was just basically so surprising because
the kid he looked so normal like a
typical all-american Caucasian American
kid and his liquid 20s he looks so much
younger he looked like a high school kid
right I was just wondering what do you
think personally drives normal kids to
commit these heinous awful acts like it
just seems that these kids these killers
are getting younger and younger and I'm
not sure what drives I mean first of all
not even the youngest I mean we've had
younger shooters than this guy even very
recently so I don't know that 24 makes
him the youngest but what do you what
does it mean to look normal like what
would what would you have expected him
to look like I guess like he had no like
signs of any obvious mental illness like
he wasn't uncashed he wasn't like he
didn't look like he didn't have any kind
of disease like you look normal he
dressed normal it was able to operate
computers just fine he was able to like
look and like walk around malls being
undetected like you just he didn't give
him up any of those typical vibes that
you would expect from someone that's
obviously mentally ill like he was from
his from the picture of him and
descriptions by like how the cops are
able to find and they were able to find
a surveillance footage yeah around I
would go around different areas around
the mall and he wouldn't like give off
any red flags he would just exist yeah
listen I mean first of all as I
mentioned earlier in the week when we
covered this I when I was thinking about
what I expect to be the description of
the bomber I expected it to be a white
male between age 20 and 45 because just
statistically that's typically what they
are so in that sense I was completely
unsurprised by the fact that it ended up
being a 24 year old white male I think
you're maybe going a little further into
some kind of
be stereotyping in terms of what the
person would look like I mean many of
these shooters and bombers existed in
society they operated computers they
wore normal clothes I mean I just I
don't know what it is that you expected
to see but I was not in any way
surprised when I saw a picture of the
guy it's fascinating
yeah so I understood like what do you
think drives these guys personally I
don't know I really don't know I mean I
think that it's a combination two things
I think one I've already talked about
how in the u.s. we have this problem
where we we are much more likely to see
acts of violence like shootings or
bombings as solutions to problems and
that's why we say hey look here's a
different country with guns but they
don't have the shooting problems it's
like yeah they have a different
relationship to the gun where they don't
see the gun as a way to solve societal
problems I think that there's a lot of
without putting any of these in order
there's a mental health component that's
going on here there's an education
component I think the sort of status quo
of just incredible inequality that
people are faced with on a day-to-day
basis plays a role I think that the work
culture is probably a factor in some way
media and vai mean there's just a whole
bunch of different things including
people who are raised in homes where
there are not the the modeling that
they're seeing around them is not
modeling that's going to get them to
sort of be what we would stereotypically
call a productive member of society even
though I hate I hate that term because I
think it's sort of like a term that has
a particular meaning in our capitalist
system and I don't really like it it's
not one thing you know so basically it's
like a synergistic motion of both things
like both environment genetics regards
that listen I I don't want to I don't
know to what extent genetics plays a
role so I don't I wouldn't even be
prepared to comment on that that's
totally fair yeah okay all right thank
you really appreciate the call and on
that note we are out of time we will
take calls again that I promise you
sorry to everybody we didn't get you do
have a lot of people holding do my best
to get to as many as possible whenever
we take